what's more thrilling than a shark
a mob of them sharks might have invented
crowdsourcing
[Music]
every year between may and july billions
of migrating sardines come to spawn off
the coast of south africa
catering one of the largest feeding
frenzies in the world
sharks make the guest list hundreds of
copper sharks swooping through a dense
oily cloud of fish
[Music]
the sardines try to thwart the attack by
banding together into a tight
shimmering disco ball when a shark
strikes
the sardines scatter and escape or at
least that's the plan
but the battle's not over while the
sharks harass the sardines from below
cape ganet's mountain aerial attack
sharks and birds corner the little
fishes
benefiting them both
air trapped in their feathers hampers
the gannett's ability to dive deep
so they have to strike hard
they hit the water head first with
arrow-like posture
folding their wings behind them to
minimize the force of impact
besieged on all sides the sardine
defense starts to fail
to make things worse a brutus whale
crashes the party
rising from the depths this 15-ton giant
devours sardines by the thousands
even the copper sharks give this 50-foot
behemoth a wide
berth
and then it's over as suddenly as it
began
[Music]
you